hi everyone i'm i'm ash Jason Momoa and
I'm Amber Heard there's a very special
exclusive look at Aquaman on the biggest
of the big screens IMAX the ideal way to
experience this movie enjoy my parents
are from different worlds
and I was a product of the love that
never should have been she could unite
our worlds one day a son of the land and
the son of the Seas
my mother always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper
you are the bridge between land and sea
your rightful place as king
[Music]
we're getting close now yeah close to
what
buying a thirst there's no way Atlantis
with this far in there check this place
out
[Music]
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert see you do your
best thinking when you're not thinking
at all all right no hold stone hey what
are you doing we need water you're the
closest source
[Music]
sure I could've just peed on it
inglis Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
if you seek my power journey beyond the
edge of the world to the hidden sea
in the wrong hands
it would bring destruction
but enhanced literal air
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what we've written it down first I
memorized it didn't you
oh yeah what are you just say something
something Trident the Beast has awakened
the time has come
for Atlantis to rise again
who the hell are you
[Music]
oh is awesome the war is coming to the
surface
you are not going to win this
billions will die unless you help us
[Music]
I'm no leader
not King
[Music]
Thank You Swiss always had a key now I
need something more
well what could be greater than a king a
[Music]
hero
hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Aquaman footage that's like
the longest trailer ever it is a vastly
polished version with some slightly
different footage from the last big
extended trailer they released so we got
to break it down James 1 the director
also clarified some things supposedly
they're also offering early tickets to
Amazon Prime members but we don't have
details on when those tickets go on sale
so if you're an Amazon Prime member you
might have a chance to see this a week
before everybody else at least in the
United States I don't know about other
places in the world so if I get more
information about that I'll post an
update but there's a new round of that
IMAX ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave an
Aquaman related comment on the video the
funny thing about this trailer too is
that it's supposed to be the IMAX
trailer it's not technically true IMAX
ratio if you go to a true IMAX theater
the aspect ratio is a little bit
different from the anamorphic ratio that
traditional theaters have but if you
don't live nearby one of those don't
worry about it so they start off with
some slightly different footage of his
birth his early life a slightly
different shot of him wrecking black
mantas submarine with a different
soundtrack you can actually see his ship
from the comics the one that looks like
an actual Manta attached to the top here
I'm guessing that he gets away in that
this is meant to be his father ship when
Aquaman takes it down
he kills black mantas father that
inspires him to take revenge in his part
of the reason why he throws in with
ocean master he gets all his comic book
gear they polished a lot of this Indiana
Jones footage where they enter the ruins
of Atlanta and if you couldn't tell from
the behind-the-scenes footage this room
where he's giving them the message about
the trident is the same room where they
forged the actual trident in all the
flashback scenes to ancient Atlantis if
you look in the background here too you
can see they're just this giant
cityscapes so you have to remember this
used to be above ground before the
Sahara was a desert that's why they
include that very on the nose line of
dialogue oh that's right this is all
buried in sand it didn't used to be that
way when you see those scenes of
Atlantis above-ground they also polished
a lot of the background of this too so
you get much clearer shots of what's
going on with these parts of the city
but you have to imagine that the city of
Atlantis was also the kingdom of
Atlantis so would be like having one
giant city that was the size of the
state of New York or something like that
like that's how big the actual sea
was because when it sank it broke into
the seven different kingdoms each of the
kingdoms when they landed on different
parts of the ocean floor were already
really big with a ton of people they all
evolved differently I've talked about
that in previous trailers that's why
they all look differently even though
they share common genetic ancestry when
they were still above the ocean you get
a whole bunch more scenes of them
beaching all these ships here with these
giant tidal waves James 1 explained that
this is actually a prelude early in the
movie to ocean masters real plan and
it's sort of his way of throwing the
gauntlet is basically him kicking all
foreign invaders as he sees them all
surface dwellers out of his domain
Earth's oceans but the funny thing about
that is that the oceans cover most of
Earth's surface so you have all over the
world all these ships just being beached
through the power of Atlantis he's just
creating these giant tidal waves that
are just crashing them on the shore mera
even refers to billions dying it'd be
interesting to explain how billions
could potentially die but the rest of
the Justice League could not be bothered
to help Aquaman out they already
explained why the Justice League isn't
supposed to be in the movie because it's
meant to be more self-contained but I'm
sure that they'll have some references
to what happened like this moment in the
bar where his father says I always knew
you were meant for great things is
probably them acknowledging what he did
during the events of Justice League we
get a little more of Aquaman's fight on
this sunken ship here I think this is
supposed to be Merck because I know he's
one of the people in these red suits
he's sort of ocean masters
second-in-command but you also noticed
that he's fighting some of these white
armor guards that his mother was
fighting in the flashbacks when he was a
baby remember like in Star Wars the
Empire has a bunch of different types of
stormtroopers all of them different
levels of elite some of them more badass
than others for various specific
functions so just imagine that the white
guards are just an extra level of
hardcore the red suits carry more armor
more weaponry but they're a little less
mobile I've already done a non-spoilery
breakdown of some of the other early
reviews of the movie you can click here
to listen to that and you can click here
to learn all about Avengers phase 4 in
that eternals movie thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]